after Donald Trump's bizarre press
conference where he attacked media and
sent out the strange media attack survey
we had some unusual individuals or at
least surprising criticized what Donald
Trump is doing so first of all right
after Trump's bizarre press conference
where he attacked the media he sent out
this media survey media accountability
survey which we have a picture of for
you and it was basically saying please
take this survey so that we can fight
back against the media's attacks and
deceptions a new unbelievably bizarre
thing to be sending out and it was
basically a pretext to slam media even
more so right after this Donald Trump
did an interview with NBC's Chuck Todd
where he said I hate the press I hate
you especially and as a result of this
we had what's our next thing it's a
Donald Trump tweet as well right Donald
Trump sending out a tweet where he said
the fake news media failing New York
Times NBC News ABC CBS CNN is not the
enemy it is not my enemy it is the enemy
of the American people okay this is very
very dangerous rhetoric and there are
both Republicans and Fox News hosts that
are saying this is insane and it must
end first we had Shepard Smith the
sometimes lone voice of remotely
reasonable thinking on Fox News he
called the entire thing crazy Jim Acosta
over there from CNN an accomplished
reporter guy I've never met but a good
reporter
I mean treating him like he's I'm not
even going to use the word I'm not going
to give Twitter it's the love it needs
it's crazy what we're watching every day
yeah it's absolutely crazy he keeps
repeating ridiculous throwaway lot
that's Fox News that conversation
happening on Fox News also from Fox News
Chris Wallace says that a line was
crossed when Trump attacked the media at
his bizarre and gong show like rally yes
presidents have always had and
politicians have always had problems
with the press they want good press the
press doesn't always give it to them but
what Jefferson
areas despite all of our disputes that
to the functioning of a free and fair
democracy you must have an independent
press and that is why so many people
were really upset when Donald Trump said
ìlook we're big boys we criticize
presidents they want to criticize us
fact that's fine but when he said that
that the fake news media is not my enemy
it's the enemy of the American people I
believe that was an important line one
of those it's sort of idiocy for Chris
Wallace to go on Fox and Friends and try
to have an adult conversation I mean
it's like talking to clueless little
kids but still Chris Wallace making his
point even if it wasn't understood by
the hosts there and then Republican
Senator John McCain saying that the
attacks on the press are how dictators
get started
stunning comments from John McCain Fox
News is standing up to Trump in some
little isolated incidents before
Republican congressman R Trump going out
of his way by the way at the press
conference to leave out fox news from
his criticism saying several times that
Fox News is actually okay they're not
part of this insane criticism this is an
incredibly dangerous situation and I've
said it before I'll say it again on a
recent YouTube livestream I said I don't
think it makes sense to say Donald Trump
is Hitler but there is no doubt that we
are seeing language now that matches the
pre-world War two authoritarian rhetoric
that we were hearing in Germany I mean
it's great to see too that there are
conservatives who have an understanding
of what the facts are and understand
there's an importance of the media in
their place in our democracy yeah but
then you also have people like
congressman Lamar Smith who said that
you can't trust the media if you get
your news directly from the President as
if or some autocracy or something
there's also something insanely
hypocritical in the background of this
which you're kind of alluding to which
is all these Trump is joining the angry
at the media at a systemic level
bandwagon how are they hearing about the
things that Donald Trump does which they
like the media and I think that it's
it's also one of those low media
literacy red flags when people don't
even understand what the source for the
stuff they know is whether it's media
you like or don't like trust or don't
like or don't trust your
still hearing about what your fearless
orange leader is saying and doing
through the media discuss this with us
on our reddit discussion forum david
pakman.com slash re d di t today's
program is made possible in part by
movement watches movement watches and by
the way I'm wearing my relatively new
movement watch this is the black face
with the blue hands which I really
really like movement watches was started
by basically two broke college guys in a
dorm room who would go to department
stores they'd see watches that they
liked and they'd be four to five hundred
dollars too expensive so instead they
cut out the middlemen and sell directly
on their website MGMT watches dot-com
and as a result watches start at just 95
bucks they've sold over 500,000 watches
at this point and people really like the
watches everywhere I go with both this
watch and the other one that that I have
some movement washes people immediately
look at it I can tell when I'm talking
people start looking at the watch and
whatever I'm saying the next thing they
say is where did you get that watch
that's really cool
and you can go to mV mt watches calm
slash Pakman to get 15% off your
movement watch today they make great
gifts you get free shipping as well as
free returns check out mV mt watches
calm slash Pakman that is PA que ma n